here in the u.s gas prices have hit
another all-time high another sign of
the inflation that's hammering american
families the average price per gallon is
now around four dollars and sixty cents
after hitting a new high nearly every
day for the past two weeks the cost of
diesel fuel also broke records last week
and keep this in mind nearly everything
we buy is delivered on a truck or a
train that runs on diesel as carter
evans explains that covers a lot of
ground and hits consumers right in the
pocket
yesterday i've seen
fuel prices like six dollars and 39
cents a gallon
imagine paying that for a fill up of
more than 100 gallons a regular fill up
would have been just say six months ago
about seven hundred dollars
now
it's about a thousand
it's what truckers are facing across the
country for diesel and you're paying the
price according to oil analyst tom clusa
if you're ordering anything that moves
by freight across the country it comes
via
fuel surcharges probably not the worst
of the diesel surcharges that'll come
next month the biden administration is
now considering tapping a rarely used
diesel reserve to help ease prices a
million barrels of diesel in this
reserve and the whole grand scheme of
things how much is that
very incidental it'll help but it
doesn't move the needle much last month
the white house tapped the strategic
petroleum reserve to help ease
skyrocketing oil prices but with
memorial day weekend coming up more than
39 million people are expected to travel
increasing demand for gasoline i just
don't think there's any magic bullet at
the moment it's going to be tough it's
going to be a tough summer andy says
fuel prices could keep rising if any
refineries were to shut down august
looks like it's going to be very active
hurricane season in the gulf of mexico
where
you know about half of our refining
capacity is on the coast anything goes
when we get to hurricane season then
that's true for gasoline it's true for
diesel and it's true for jet fuel for
cbs warnings i'm carter evans in los
angeles